let's get started so I'm going to talk
about uh row Hammer row press and Beyond
and I have this title over here that
probably everybody knows the answer to
but maybe we can discuss that at the
end uh how many people know this
bridge okay where is what is it the
common arrows how many people have been
over
it probably zero because this is what
happened to that bridge in 1940 it's a
bit flip and this is a bit flip that
clearly in important infrastructure like
Bridges and uh it's taught in civil
engineering classes as a classic example
of how not to build Bridges let's say
but we're going to get back to Bridges
at the end of this talk uh in a little
bit but this is also an example of a
reliability issue that caused a Safety
and Security problem and in this talk
I'm going to cover a reliability issue
that's caused a Safety and Security
problem as well I'll also ask you this
question how secure do you think these
people are they look quite happy you
don't need to answer if they get a bit
flip they will not be happy soon so I
think of security as preventing
unforeseen consequences you can replace
that security with safety over here as
well probably now this is Miss
robustness yes exactly I had that in the
in my abstract I'm going to get back to
robustness essentially robustness is
safety security reliability combined
together
uh this is Mr Bean you may have seen
this and clearly he is foreshadowing the
future and if you have infrastructure
that looks like this which is going to
be much more common than bridges of
course driven by somebody else other
than Mr be bling strings and if you get
buil flips in this we may not be
very happy going into the future and
this infrastructure will be all over the
place there are billions of devices that
are going to be around
us okay so what is row Hammer why am i
showing you all these pictures
essentially rammer is the fact that you
can predict induced bit flips in
commodity chips the first time we tested
this problem we saw that more than 80%
of the tested chips were vulnerable
today it's 100% but I'm going to give
you the story of it also and
interestingly this is as far as we know
the first example of how a simple
Hardware failure mechanism can create a
widespread system security vulnerability
if you know of something else please let
me know I'll correct my slid and people
are writing interesting thing uh
articles like this forget software now
hackers are exploiting physics I like
this because this kind of get to the
core of the problem if you will so I'm
going to give you a little bit of story
of how we stumbled on this and what
we've done and what people have done uh
and hopefully we can have a good
discussion feel free to interrupt me
with any question that you may have at
any point so we've been working on
memory reliability problems for a while
I was invited to give this talk at the
international memory Workshop in 2013
where we argued that these problems are
going to get much worse and we will need
to take a systems and Architectural
perspective to solve these problems so
what is the problem that we're going to
look at specifically in the memory side
there are a lot of issues in other
memory Technologies as well but we're
going to focus on DRM and if you look at
DRM DRM stores charge uh in capacitor
let me see this not working very well so
I'm going to use my pointer over here
you have you need to have a storage
device and you need to have an access
device and both of these need to work
very well essentially reliable and as
you reduce the size of the circuit uh
the reliability maintaining that
reliability becomes a challenge and you
get noise a lot of noise and as a result
capacity cost and energy hard to scale
in DM and this is a virtual picture if
you will the physical DM looks like this
it's like a honeycomb structure which is
very interesting also so there are a lot
of interesting effects that we're not
going to go into I'm not going to go
into the device level over here but I'd
be happy to talk about that basically DM
is used in all memories today that we
build all main memories and we wanted to
understand the reliability issues this
is one of the large scale studies that
we did with Facebook in 2015 that was
published in 2015 what we did was we
analyzed all of the memory areas in all
of their data centers this is actually a
lot lot of memory a lot of servers they
didn't allow us to publish how much
memory how many servers because they
were worried that this would affect this
would give out the side of their Fleet
and affect their stock price Etc but
imagine that it's a nice correlational
study so what we found out is that uh
the GM chip density that's employed in
the server is strongly correlated with
the server failure rate that you're
getting at the system level at the
application Level we can go into a lot
of detail over here I'm not going to do
that but basically the denser the DM
chip you get more errors and this areas
happens because the cells are smaller
and cells are closer to each other so
there a lot more reliability and noise
issues and you can read the paper if
you're interested people have written
papers that build on this paper also
from um AMD Microsoft Etc they're
interesting so of course with a large
scale study you cannot really pinpoint
some of the issues so we also wanted to
build an fpj based infrastructure to
understand some of
the lowlevel issues that we can uh that
that happen with DM and we're going to
look at retention failure and latency
and row hammer in this so basically
these are PJ based infrastructure where
you can modify the memory controller and
the memory controller CH can change the
commands that you can issue to the so
that we can test essentially anything
that that the interface allows by
violating the timing parameters for
example by not refreshing DM we can
figure out different things and this is
the infrastructure that we used to do a
lot of the r Hammer studies we open
sourced it in 2017 and more recently we
actually open sourced a newer version of
it in 2022 uh that can test ddr4 chips
if people are interested in actually
doing studies on DM we'd be happy to
support it we've been supporting people
to do that so why did we build this
infrastructure we actually wanted to
test these reliability issues and one of
the major reliability issue that we
wanted to test was Data retention if D
DM is dynamic Random Access Memory it
needs to refresh frequently and we said
basically if you refresh frequently if
you actually reduce the size of the cell
and the cells get closer to each other
you need to refresh things much more
frequently and we wanted to avoid that
and we wanted to understand how the
retention time profile of DM looks like
and exploit that and this is actually
very well known but we validated it most
of the DM cells don't T refresh
frequently and we wanted to understand
can we actually enable real mechanisms
that avoid refreshes in the so that your
power doesn't uh explode and your your
battery doesn't die for example because
of DRM refreshes my cell phone for
example is refreshing it DRM in my
pocket right now unnecessarily I would
say okay I'm not going to tell you the
story about refreshes there's actually a
very very interesting story in retention
over here because this is very much
tougher problem than this picture shows
it's very difficult to identify these
cells that can be refreshed at different
rates uh but we written papers about it
that I'm going to skip so while we were
doing these studies we were actually
doing a lot of studies with flash memory
as well I'm going to show you a picture
of infrastructure with flash memory and
in flash memory there are a lot of
errors and one of the issues about R
disturbance errors and together with
Intel we wanted to actually analyze the
read disturbance areas in DM as well so
what is r Hammer essentially R Hammer is
a read disturbance mechanism this is a
an array in DM you have rows of cells
each cell stores one bit of value if you
want to read a value in one row you need
to open or activate that row meaning
apply high voltage to that word line now
if you want to read some other row you
need to close this row it's called
pre-charging DM apply low voltage low
voltage that word line now if you keep
doing this repeatedly open close open
close activate precharge activate
precharge activate pre-charge
essentially we found out that physically
adjacent rows get bit flips in
vulnerable cells and clearly this should
not be happening right because nothing
should be changing in memory we're just
activating a row but now you're actually
corrupting data in nearby cells this
this data can be belonging to your own
application or some other application
the operating system as a result this is
a data corruption problem that could
affect your safety it's clearly
reliability also but security also
because these bit flips can be taken
advantage of as I will describe in a
little bit so we call this the hammer Dr
we call these the victim rows and we
show that essentially more than 80% of
the chips that are manufactured by PR
major manufacturers are vulnerable to
this problem there are only three major
manufacturers in the world there are
some others that are interesting but
they're also vulnerable by the way it's
interesting
okay yeah
sorry million err
C you know like number of bits over a
certain number of bits I I believe a
bank in this case yeah don't take these
numbers so literally it's based on some
experiments but certain certain
hammering pattern and certain number of
yes
yes I don't know the exact like Bank
size Etc spal exactly it's spatial
certainly
yes so here for example it's errors per
10 to the N cells over here it's kind of
that metric yeah so this is also a
scaling problem because the chips that
we tested that were manufactured before
2010 were not at least we were not able
to induce bit flips Ro Hammer we
disturbance bit flips like this uh but
the chips that were manufactured in 2010
where we showed the F we showed the
first appearance of these bit flips and
all the chips that were manufactured
between 2012 and 2013 were well new I
should also say that this is not the
best way of inducing bit flips I'm going
to talk a little bit more about a better
way of inducing bit flips so there might
be bit flips in later generations that
we weren't able to discover over here
for example so you may actually find
that anom so why is this happening at
this in this talk I'm not going to go
into the Silicon level device failure
mechanisms but cross talk is one reason
why this is happening electron electron
migration injection is another reason
why this is happening
these are being studied also but
basically the issue is DRM cells are too
close to each other they're not
electrically isolated from each other
access to one cell affects the values of
nearby cells due to this electrical
interference between the cells as well
as the wires used for accessing the
cells it's essential cell to cell
coupling interference I like this high
level abstract picture I use this
actually for freshman when I teach this
to freshman for example when you
activate apply high voltage to a row an
adjacent row gets slightly activated as
well clearly I'm violating some low
level abstraction here but vulnerable
cells in that slightly activated row
lose a little bit of charge and if row
Hammer happens enough times charge and
such cells get drained and as a result
you get data corruption okay and this
actually has enormous implications on
the software hierarchy because these
bits these bit flips actually get
directly exposed to the programming
language operating system and
essentially memory it's very different
from flash where storage the bit flips
inside the storage don't get directly
exposed to anything that's running
immediately okay so what's worse about
this is that when we wrote the paper we
also released this code that showed that
with with this six lines of code x86
code you can actually induce these bit
flips what this code does is it selects
addresses X and Y such that they map to
the same bank and uh it basically avoids
caches cach it for from the CPU and
avoids Rob buffer hits in the DRM and
ping pongs activates to xmy Rose xmy and
if the chip is vulnerable you'll get bit
flips in this paper we also that if X
and Y are selected such that there's
only one row sandwich between X and Y
you get a lot more bit flip that's
called double-sided haming but in most
of the experiments in our paper was
single-sided hammering double-sided
hammering is actually much worse because
you increase the electrical interference
that happens coupling essentially and we
observed erors and real systems with
that code uh I'm not going to harp harp
upon these real system all of the real
systems that employ uh a good enough
memory controller and this sort of
memory gets bit flips so it's a real
reliability security and issue so we in
the paper we said that basically the
first sentence as you can see is memory
isolation is a key property of a
reliable and secure Computing system and
access to one memory address should not
have unintended side effects on data
stored another addresses I still
strongly believe that and we basically
said that if this does not get
controlled someone can hijack your
computer and the good folks from Google
project zero red our paper they
basically said okay we can do this and
they actually created a beautiful attack
I'm not going to go over this in detail
and this is actually copy paste directly
from their blog post they have a
beautiful blackout presentation about
this also they basically said they
replicated the problem on a selection of
laptops and they wrote a they wrote two
programs one is more interesting than
the other one was able to induce bit
flips and uh essentially escape the
sandbox of the Google native client
virtual machine essentially but the
other one was a as a user level process
it was able to gain Cal privileges in
x864 Linux so the way they achieved this
was they were able to hammer page table
and
that point to the page table of the
program and they induce bit flips on the
page table entries that point to the
page table of the program and by
flipping the right bits they would gain
right access to the page table which is
essentially the protection mechanism
that we have in virtual memory today and
once you gain right access to your own
page table essentially all bets are off
you can do anything to that
computer and it's a beautiful paper I
recommend people to look at that Google
project Zer work later this became
famous as the D Hammer vulnerability I
like this uh written by famous hacker on
Twitter it's like Ro Hammer is like
breaking to an apartment by repeatedly
slamming a neighbor's door until the
vibrations open the door you were after
so if you're kind of magically stuck in
this room don't worry stop banging on
the walls and hopefully magically the
door will open if rammer is in effect
was there a question in the back
yes
neighbor is there easy for this there's
no application requires
so
so we're going to talk about Solutions
yes we're going to get get to the fixes
it's it looks easy but there's a story
behind this
also very good any other questions okay
yes were they able to Target specifics
like using certain PN it they it well
they they crafted a special attack
because this is not easy to do so they
they sprayed the memory with page tables
so that they increase the probability of
the attack so in the end it's a
probabilistic attack yes but but they
they uh if you attack for example just
the right enable bit in your page table
entry that points to your own page table
that's one out of 64 bits the
probability is very low but if you spray
the page spray the memory with many page
tables now you change the pointer to a
page table entry and you actually
increase the probability of the attack
significantly yeah yeah and then later a
lot of clever Works in security and suit
so these fls from T for example showed
that they could gain unrestricted access
to systems of website Visitors by doing
this on JavaScript which is interesting
this is actually a nice work from kav's
group who's at eth right now basically
they showed that uh they basically
created an app and this app was able to
hammer your memory and take control of
your phone because by exploiting some
deterministic deterministic memory
allocation batters I'm not going to go
through these all in detail people
accelate this using gpus people were
able to do this using the remote direct
memory access interface across the
network and this is another paper that
talks about that even if you cannot take
over another system this paper showed
that you could bake confidentiality by
using roow hammer bit flips they could
read someone else's memory private
memory that they should not be able to
read and more recently people have been
also looking at bit flip attacks using
rowhammer on neural networks and other
ways otherwise nice neural network uh
inference engine accelerator or CPU
that's reasonably accurate may become
actually completely inaccurate if you
actually induce these row Hammer bit
flips and there are a lot of Works in
this area these are some examples and I
could go on and on in security community
but maybe there's another attack to your
computer or maybe there another solution
of course that's a joke okay so let uh
we've been writing a lot of papers on
this I'm first going to talk about some
initial understanding that we've
developed and then we're going to talk
about what happened uh afterwards but
feel free to ask questions this is we
can make this more interactive so this
was the first rammer analysis and this
is the infrastructure that we used to
actually analyze rammer we tested 129
modules that were manufactured in those
years as you can see and I'm not going
to go through all of the results I'm
going to pick and choose some of them
this is an interesting one because this
uh we're going to look at The Logical
adjacency of the aggressor and victim
roles not the physical adjacency logical
adjacency means from the memory
controller's perspective where are the
addresses the is the aggressor adjacent
to the victim in most cases they're one
apart meaning they're adjacent but there
are some cases where they're not
adjacent now this means we we
hypothesize that this is because there's
some internal remapping of row add
that's going on in D for fault tolerance
reasons for other reasons Etc uh that's
logically unist now what's the
significance of the significance is that
if you actually want to implement a
defense in the memory controller you
don't know where the rows are you need
to figure the out first so you need to
reverse engineer or you need to come up
with an interface where the memory
exposes the adjacency of the row which
the manufacturers are in general very
against doing what's say and we can talk
about that also okay so another
characteris this is actually real chips
based on these are all data from real
chips from our 2014 paper so okay you
can say okay I can reduce the frequency
of activations the uh DM and I can get
rid of this problem and you're
absolutely right and we wanted to test
this basically the way you activate at
the time was every 52.5 NCS you can
issue and activate if you reduce that to
every 500 NS in the chips we tested you
could actually get rid of this problem
so this is called throttling of the
applications this is a bad idea if you
apply it across the board because this
would reduce your performance greatly as
you can see and uh basically here these
are the worst chips that we tested and
these are the worst are basically you
can actually get rid of all the areas
that we've seen but remember that our
patterns may not be the worst at the
time so this actually much worse the so
this is not a great solution but we're
going to get back to this you can say oh
I can actually increase the refresh
ratees of the and uh this way if I
increase the refresh rate to a level uh
hopefully someone will not be able to
activate a row enough times before the
cells get refreshed right and if you do
that yes you actually get rid of the
errors as you can see but you need to
increase your refresh interval by
refresh rate by 7x and nobody wants that
because remember the reason why we
actually wanted to build our
infrastructure was to get rid of
refreshes we don't want to add more
refreshes to actually solve this problem
so but we're going to get back to this
refreshes because this is the only lever
that industry had at the time to fix
this problem okay data pattern is
interesting because different data
patterns because of the different charge
level they have across the cells C cause
different uh coupling capacitance across
the cells as a result different data
patterns have different implications you
can see that you get 10x errors with the
data pattern on the
right okay there are other observations
here I think errors are repeatable is
interesting because uh if an error is
repeatable that means that you can
figure out which bits are vulnerable and
you can you can create a security attack
based on which bits are vulnerable uh
ECC is not a good solution to this
problem we can get back to this uh and
as I said double-sided hammering is much
worse than single-sided hammering okay
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
more story basically this was 2014 and
as the gentleman over there mentioned
that we thought this problem would be
fixed but it didn't get fixed and we're
going to talk about why so we actually
analyzed this again in 2020 and we show
that it's getting much worse I'm going
to talk about that it has many
dimensions and there are a lot of
interesting studies that you can do it
affects the hbm chips as well and
perhaps more so as we I'm not going to
discuss that in detail but let me jump
into the solutions at the time and then
we're going to talk about some of these
things any
questions okay so let's talk about
Solutions so clearly if you have such a
problem you need to have an immediate
fix of the problem because there are all
of these DS out there and you need to
fix that right so clearly we have
limited possibilities because our memory
controllers are not intelligent let's
say but longer term you can actually do
a lot of things you can change the DM
you can change the memory control you
can change the software you can change
everything we're going to talk about
that so in our ESA paper we propose both
types of solutions which are currently
implemented many things in different
varant we propos one solution as the
best but it's not working today I'm
going to discuss that also so these are
some solution approaches I'm going to uh
say that robust
dmips this is in in research but it's
very difficult to do this at low cost
air quaking codes are a bad idea because
air quaking codes are uh good for random
erors whose causes you don't know here
you know the cause exactly so you can
actually build a circuitry to fix the
problem and save your expensive air
correcting codes for things that you
don't know increasing the refresh rate
and also air correcting codes are
difficult to do because you get actually
a lot of Errors within a code word
increasing the refresh rate is a bad
solution today but we're going to talk
about that physical isolation is
interesting but a lot of the solutions
actually are not secure so the two
solutions two major Solutions uh uh that
we are left with today mostly are
reactive refresh meaning you count how
many activations you get for a
particular row and refresh the adjacent
rows in some way either
probabilistically or deterministically
or proac throttle meaning figure out
which rows are likely to be hammered and
proac throttle accesses so you don't
Hammer them more such that you don't get
a bit flip hopefully that makes sense so
there's a huge space in terms of cost
power performance complexity you can
have security over there also and safety
uh in terms of the tradeoff space and
people have been developing a lot of
interesting Solutions in the space I'm
going to show you some examples so what
did industry do initially essentially
they increase the refresh rates because
this is what they can do there's no
other option if you will they cannot
change the DM chips out in the field
apple is nice because they actually
creit our paper over here and they don't
say how much they increase the refresh
rates probably by 2x so you can see that
they Clos the vulnerability but probably
they didn't completely fix the
vulnerability and it's everybody Hasen
released similar patches so what was our
solution at the time the solution
doesn't work today as I will show you in
a little bit but our solution was
problemistic adjacent Ro activation
essentially we changed the memory
controller or the DM chip and when the
memory controler Clos a row it activates
its neighbors with a very low
probability so that's a probabilistic
solution and we show that you get a
reasonably good reliability guarantee if
you're not happy with that reliability
guarantee increase the value of p and
with a reasonable reliability guarantee
we show that this is low power low
energy it's stateless also so there's a
lot of advantages I like the solution
still but unfortunately today it doesn't
work as we will see because the row
Hammer threshold has gone down to very
low amount so the number of activates uh
that you need to induce bit flips has
gone down to levels of 1,000 or so today
1,000 2,000 as I will show you at the
time we test our chips it was 139,000 so
this problem is becoming much worse okay
so this could be this sort of solution
can be implement the DM chip or in the
memory controller I will not go into the
details of this Intel actually
implemented a version of the solution in
their memory controller this is not
exactly how we envisioned it but in the
bios for example you can pick your row
Hammer solution you can either pick
Hardware row Hammer protection or 2x
refresh and if you have Hardware Ro
Hammer protection you have another
screen over here where you can choose
the rammer activation problem hopefully
you're not going to choose one over two
then every activation you're going to
get a refresh which is probably not good
but they actually this person actually
said that one over to the 11 that was
our kind of
recommendation in the paper okay uh so
this is an example of an intelligent
control this is a slightly intelligent
controller as you can see that can do
problemistic activation I think we we
need a lot more intelligent controllers
to solve the sort of issues and uh here
I will mention that we've been doing a
lot of work on flash memory this is the
fpj based infrastructure where we
actually built a lot of SSD controllers
to understand the issues with flash
memory and we have these intelligent
controls in flash memory The Flash
translation layer in flash memory does a
has a lot of intelligence has a lot of
understanding of the device
characteristics to fix many different
types of errors that are going on in
flash memory and if you're interested we
written a paper on it some time ago we
need something like that in the I will
argue okay so uh going forward I think
we need to understand ROP Hammer this is
a researchy slide I'm going to get back
to what has happened but there are many
effects that still need to be rigorously
examined like aging enironmental
conditions memory access patterns the
system design is make uh without
understanding I don't think we can
easily solve this problem solving Ro is
also important than the question is how
do we solve it I think we need flexible
and efficient Solutions and also in
field programmable Solutions because you
may actually find an effect that you
don't know of as I as we will discuss I
think Co architecting system and memory
is important to avoid performance and
denial of service problems if this is to
high level I'd be happy to talk about
more detail any
questions yes please so you know of
course you know you could go and Hammer
and then you can use with but if you
just run you know normal applications
yes you know and and you're not trying
to do anything
adversarial then you know do you see no
Hammer problems so that's an excellent
question so we did not try to do that uh
actually we're looking at that right now
I think I think currently it's a lot
easier to do that
but uh one of the uh industry actually
discovered this problem uh because it
happened in a real application and
there's a nice talk uh from an Intel
principal engineer that was delivered at
year MC uh this year I don't know I
don't know if it's on YouTube I didn't
put it online that basically describes
how they discovered it so it happens in
real applications for example I'll give
you the basic idea of how real
application may look like uh there's
actually Isa 2022 paper from Microsoft
that shows that there's a coherence in
this hammering essentially if you if you
have a cash block that many processes
are trying to access and that's
non-cashable that's in memory you cause
a lot of robot for conflicts in that
particular cash block because there's
some contention memory contention and as
a result you may actually get a bit flip
in a real application without someone
trying to do this uh
maliciously which is scary I think
because as rammer threshold goes down
the probability of that increases in
existing systems yes setting aside like
the other challenges complications of
memories that are not
charged you know if you were to just use
those is that automatically solve every
problem or still things that come
up yeah I mean so okay I'll any scaled
memory will have some sort of
reliability issue and we'll have some
sort of disturbance issue and it will
get to some level for example flash
memory well flash memory is charge based
okay maybe it doesn't answer your
question but flash memory has actually
even worse R disturbance issues but
people have shown that in sttm round for
example you have Ro Hammer there are
papers that are written on that they
call gr Hammer but it's a some sort of R
disturbance issue so I don't believe
that any memory is immune to this
problem at this
point these are great questions okay so
uh what happened basically so Intel
actually had this
uh solution but Intel turned this turned
off the solution because the
manufacturers in around 2018 17 through
19 claimed that they actually sold Ro
Hammer they basically said okay our ddr4
chips are Ro Hammer free you don't need
to have these Solutions in your memory
controller and that's essentially what
happened and we questioned that so we
actually did multiple works that tried
to understand Ro Hammer one of them is
more device level we're trying to
understand Ro Hammer by turning off all
of the solutions uh I'm going to give
you the key idea basically we tested a
lot more chips than we did in 2014 we
found out that newer DM chips are much
more vulnerable to row Hammer we get
more bit flips that are happening
earlier and there are new Chips whose
weakest cells fail after only 4,800
hammers so this number was 139,000
earlier as I mentioned and essentially
existing mitigation mechanisms are not
effective let me give you basically we
test a lot of chips from a lot of
different Generations building a lot of
more a lot more infrastructure than I
mentioned earlier let me give you one
example over here uh this picture shows
Hammer count which is the number
uh sorry number of activations or
hammers that you need to do to induce
the first bit flip and on on the x-axis
y- axis you have the r Hammer with flip
rate and these are data generated from
ddr4 old as you can see when you go to
the new Chips uh this curve shifts to
the left and goes up meaning that you
can induce bit flips earlier and you can
induce more bit flips and that's
consistent across all manufacturers as
you can see over here and many
Technologies also okay how do the uh
mitigation mechanisms Fair the these are
simulation results and again we see the
same on the x-axis this is the number of
paret required to the first we're
marching from left to right as you can
see this is over there and this is what
we tested as the lowest about 4,800 I
believe but as you can see we're
marching from left to right so
increasing the pressure is a terrible
pollution on the y axis you see normaliz
system performance your system
performance tanks as you can see protic
adjacent R activation if you want to get
rid of every single bit flip at some
point it becomes a terrible solution as
you can see over here so ideal mechanism
is not bad uh and this is by some
definition of ideal actually a really
ideal mechanism would be even better but
we're far from ideal over here as you
can see so there's this paper show that
there's a lot more to do essentially we
also studied new her Hammer
characteristics there are many
dimensions over here understanding this
problem is actually quite fascinating I
think we wanted to understand the
relationship with temperature and
aggress active time and spatial locality
of the areas like victim cells physical
location and we found out some
interesting things by our with our study
we found out that there's no easy
relationship between Ro Hammer
vulnerability and temperature different
cells have different vulnerabilties this
very different from retention this very
different from what I'm going to show
you later also if the aggressor is
active for a longer time you get
actually more bit flips we're going to
delve into that more and there's a lot
of spatial variance variation in terms
of the a in certain physical regions of
the DM you actually get a lot more erors
so all of these observations actually
can be used to build better defenses and
better attacks I'll give you one example
I'm going to talk about this later on a
little bit more yes
please
yeah we're gonna get to that we're gonna
get to that I'm I'm keeping the suspense
here
sure no none of them was provided to the
public yeah basically but we know what
they did because we can reverse
engineered chips and that's essentially
what we did in the next work that I'm
going to
discuss okay so basically this is an
example if you actually keep the RO
active for a longer time you can reduce
the activation count uh to induce bit
flips and if your rowhammer defense is
configured in such a way to not take
into account this one you can actually
get bit flips in a chip with uh defense
spatial variation is interesting we have
a paper coming up that takes advantage
of the spatial variation so you can see
that 10% of the D chips are a lot more
vulnerable than the rest of the 90% of
the DM chips in general it's a ballpark
and you can take advantage of that to
build a defense Improvement and I'm not
going to talk about temperature if
you're interested you can take a look at
so we did a lot more analysis I'm not
going to bore you with World line
voltage this is actually fascinating to
me because it's a voltage issue and we
actually built a lot more infrastructure
to test voltage uh change the word line
voltage and you can say that uh you can
intuitively say that if you reduce the
road line voltage you would reduce the
vulnerability because you're not causing
a lot more disturb you're causing less
disturbance and that's true but
unfortunately reducing the W line
voltage is not great for data retention
time and also activation latency so
you're in a tough trade-off space over
here so there are no easy let's say
fixes that you can do by playing with
voltage for
example okay and hbm chips talk to me
about it I'd be happy to talk about it
this actually uh hbm chips are just as
vulnerable as any other chip essentially
okay now let me talk about what the
industry did industry basically
introduced this TR solution it's called
Target row refesh it's documented in the
ddr4 standard but it doesn't say what is
done basically memory controller somehow
or or the chip itself uh does some
Target draw refes it's very nebulous we
wanted to understand what this is
essentially basically we wanted we
essentially refuted this claim that TR
protected the ships are vulnerable to R
Hammer uh and uh to to be able to do
that we introduced a new new type of
attack this called many sided row Hammer
attack remember that actually without
any solution double-sided row row hammer
should be one of the worst type of row
Hammer attacks but if there's a solution
inside the DM chip that keeps track of
how many times you activate the RO and
refresh adjacent RS that was our
hypothesis you can overflow those tables
that are inside the DM that keeps track
of the rols by actually hammering many
rolls instead of just hammering one or
two RS and we were able to do that
basically we were able to bypass those
TR mitigations by overflowing those
tables internally essentially to be able
to do that we need to use our fpj based
infrastructure to reverse engineer what
was happening inside the DM chips and
also the memory
controllers and we provide an automatic
Tool uh that actually created these many
sided R attacks and ddr4 and lpddr4
chips that were tght to be not
vulnerable so this is an example of a
many side attack red rows are the
aggressor
rows blue rows are the victim rows as
you can see so it's this is assisted
double side three side attack and four
side attack and you can see that even
though we don't get bit flips with one
or two side attacks we can get FPS in
this particular module after five side
attacks in this particular case nine
side attacks
Etc and we were able to induce bit flips
in 30% of the modules from all three
major manufacturers as you can see in
some cases the most effect effective
attacks were 19 sighted clearly there's
a trade-off over here if you increase
the number of rows that you're hammering
you have fewer number of activations
that you can do in all of those rows
within a refresh interval right so it's
not you won't get a easy curve over
here percentage
ofs a lot
actually it's actually like we were able
to induce 99% uh bit flips in 99% of
the of the bits after you bypass all
these
mitigations this is not the latest
work like whatever
reasonable refresh M and stuff like that
yeah what perent I mean I don't know the
exact percentage it depends on the
manufacturer but uh I believe okay 99%
of the rows you can induce I don't know
the exact bits bit count
sure yes expensive
yes
like
yes it's a very costly test I agree yeah
extremely
costly yeah yeah especially if you
include all of those Dimensions that we
talked about yeah yeah I agree with
you okay so we showed that this attack
works on mobile phones and different
types of attacks can be actually induced
in chips that are uh claimed to be not
vulnerable so this is the summary
basically I've already mentioned all of
these I think so these results were
actually just scratching the surface our
tool was not exhaust
and we basically said that there's a lot
more room for uncovering more vulnerable
chips than phones and we did that next I
will describe but what did the industry
do as a result basically our key
takeaways was roam is still an open
problem and we argued that security by
obscurity is likely not a good solution
I still believe that and Industry is
still going through the security by
obscurity path and we're going to talk
about the stateof thee art solutions
that are being
implemented okay so based on these two
Works mainly uh Jed actually finally
Comm based on also the push from m
Microsoft Google these hypers scalers
they basically communed the rammer group
again let's say and they basically
pushed out these two white papers if
you're interested you can take a look at
them some of them are hard to eat but
they at least start working on the prom
more seriously than before okay what we
did later was actually uncovered
essentially what was going on in the DM
ship I will not go into the details of
this it's actually very interesting uh
we were able to use the data retention
failures as a side channel to detect
when a r is refreshed by a dmip internal
if you can actually profile the
retention time of DRM row you know
exactly when when a DRM row should lose
its value but if it doesn't lose its
value then somebody must be refreshing
it internally and by using the site
Channel we figured out exactly how these
internal DM mitigation mechanism were
working this is the beauty of retention
and uh refresh and you can see this like
huge table over here but different uh
different manufacturers use different
mechanisms like in a Samsung they use
crabas mechanisms their capacity is
different it's per bank and they do a
lot of interesting things but we were
able to bypass all of the mitigations
and all of the that you tested and we
showed that you could actually get up to
row seven roham bit flips in eight by
data word and this was a number that I
was quoting 99% 99.9% of row in a bank
experience at least one row herid flip
but I have to get you the number of
percent percentage across the
entire that's true we have that actually
I have this over here this is the
distribution over here yeah but a lot
percentage may still have a reasonable
number so ECC is not a at least not a
cost effective solution of course you
can make your ECC very strong but it's
very expensive also
Che that's true check sum but that could
also be
yeah yeah yes correct it won't correct
but it can
detect I agree I agree but we want to I
think maybe we'll get we want to get rid
of all of these bit flips right we don't
want to uh have any
corruption okay so industry was also
working on it which is interesting
Microsoft did a lot of work on this
topic but Google introduced a very
interesting attack they call this the
health double there are a lot of
interesting internal mechanisms but they
basically showed that with uh if you you
can have a far aggressor this is a far
aggressor this uh bold uh red one and if
you Hammer that many times and if you
Hammer a near aggressor very little
times you get errors in this victim now
this may not sound that interesting this
actually very interesting because this
makes the defense mechanism an attack
itself why because if you're hammering
the fire aggressor the defense mechanism
would be refreshing the near aggressor
and the defense mechanism itself would
be working as an attack so that's the
problem basically that's why this is so
fascinating I think okay so your defense
mechanism need to take into account this
one also going into the future so I'm
going to talk about defense mechanism a
little bit a little bit more about
intelligent memory controller I'm going
to give you another idea that doesn't
scale very well uh even though we came
up with it our goal was to actually
scale with woring gr vulnerability and
be compatible with existing commodity DM
chips without changing any of the
interface or the chips and the idea over
here I think it has Merit still but it
needs to work it needs to become made be
made more scalable essentially we use
area efficient balloom filters and the
memory controller to detect potential uh
aggressor rows and we selectively thr
accesses to those rows and such that bit
flips do not occur you can prove the
security properties of this and if one
of the benefits of this sort of
detections you can optionally inform the
system software about the attack also
so this works if your row Hammer
threshold goes down to 1,000 meaning
1,000 activations can go as a bit flip
but if it goes below which is the regime
we're going towards today the solution
actually has higher overheads so this is
another example of an intelligent memory
controller I believe that we need to be
building okay so we're going we go back
to these Solutions what did the industry
do finally so this is uh from February
2023 finally a major D manufacturer
acknowledged the problem by writing a
paper about it at iscc and they talk
about their Solutions SK HX and they
essentially implemented a lot of the
variants of the ideas that were
disclosed in Prior research what they
did was they actually modified the DM
chip this was something that nobody
thought people would do but they
actually added counting cells
essentially for every row they added a
cell to count how many activations there
was and there's a small memory
controller inside there that refreshes
adjacent RS they don't talk about the
details of their mechanism but they say
that they reduced the RO vulnerability
to 7% whatever that means we don't know
if that's true that remains to be of
course uh examined but this is a step in
the right direction in my opinion but I
believe the turn DM interfaces do not
allow this to be nice let's say we're
going to talk about that of course
Samsung after they saw sk's paper at ISC
they had to put a paper on archive that
talks about their mechanisms their
mechanisms are also an approximate
counting based mechanism which is Al
interesting this is very hard to to read
but you can take a look at it so okay
the question is of course Are We Now Ro
Hammer free I'm not going to answer that
question but I'm going to answer
something that says maybe we have other
things to worry about also in addition
to R
Hammer any questions so
far okay so I'm going to talk about drw
press this is something that we
demonstrated at this isca this is
another red disturbance phenomenon that
caus bit flips in real D chips and it's
actually different from the rowhammer
vulnerability but it amplifies rowhammer
vulnerability and we demonstrate on real
dmips and also using a user level
program we demonstrate the proof of
concept let's say we provide some
solutions also so what's the problem
basically I mentioned to you earlier
that keeping a DRM Row open for a long
time cause bit flips and adjacent rows
but in this particular case we kept the
DRM Row open for much longer and we saw
actually very few activations are needed
to cause bit flips in some extreme cases
where you violate the timing param only
one activation is enough this is
fascinating to me because you
essentially activate one rope and you
you wait for 30 milliseconds charge gets
depleted in another R adjacent R clearly
this is violating parameters but uh it's
still interesting from a device
perspective uh so basically why did we
want to look at this essentially if you
have a solution that looks like this uh
if that doesn't rely on a high
activation count you can bypass it with
this sort of mechanism this is my
students drawing I like that one but
basically instead of relying on a high
activation count like Ro hammer tax used
to do this is the minimum activ uh
minimum Row open time that you can have
in DM just keep the row open for a
longer time which increases the
disturbance that happens to the adjacent
row then you need very few activations
essentially that's the idea and these
are real numbers from one particular
chip and we of course uh Amplified our
infrastructure to test this and at this
point we're actually releasing the names
of the manufacturers at at some point we
were not but uh I think uh people can
replicate our results much better
so essentially there are two key
conclusions that we have R press
significantly amplifies while a to read
disturbance and has a different
underlying mechanism than row
Hammer uh so these are results from real
chips this is the row Hammer uh domain
let's say you keep the row open only for
36 NCS this is where you keep the row
open for 7.8 microseconds which is
allowed by the standard you keep the row
open by 7. 70.2 micros which is also
Allowed by the standard if you actually
push the refreshes or pull the refreshes
early you can see that there's a clear
reduction in the number of activations
that you need to do to induce the first
bit flip and at 30 milliseconds all of
the chips well yeah essentially all of
the chips from all manufacturers get bit
flips so this is the number basically
you you reduce your activation count by
one to two or Jo magnitude interestingly
this phenomenon gets much worse as
temperature increases this also
indicates that this is different from
row Hammer the underlying disturbance
mechanism and a different set of cells
actually get corrupt compared to roh
hammer and there are different in terms
of access patterns and temperature
changes as our paper discussed I'm not
going to go into all of these details
since we don't have
time so we also developed a proof of
concept using an Intel Comet L processor
and a real module that has roow Hammer
protection and uh basically our
hypothesis was we could keep the row
open by accessing the cache blocks in
the same row uh uh using a program and
the memory control would hopefully keep
the roll open existing memory controls
most of them have adaptive roll open
policies if you keep accessing the C
blocks in the same row they keep the row
open because they want to improve robot
for locality and that's what we did
essentially of course you need to this
program is a bit more complicated than
this because you need to synchronize
with refreshes Etc but we vary this
parameter number of each that
essentially changes the number of cach
blocks that you access in a row and with
the row Hammer plastic row Hammer we
don't see bit flips but as you increase
the number of cash block reads you see
you start seeing bit
flips and there's clear a trade off
after some point if you actually we too
many cach blocks you cannot Hammer the
rows enough times that's why those bit
flips go to zero after some
point okay so how do you fix this
problem so clearly uh you can fix it by
adapting the Roam mitigations and that
was our proposal there are other fixes
that you can discuss like changing the
DM Etc that we also discuss in the paper
but I'm not going to discuss here but if
you already have a roow hammer
mitigation in place the key idea here is
to limit the maximum Row open time first
don't make it infinite or 70.2 micros
make it something small so that you can
exp some robot for locality at least for
performance but configure the RO Hammer
mitigation basically roam mitigation
kicks in based on some roow Hammer
threshold so that you can actually
account for the reduction in activation
counts that leads to a bit flip such
that row Hammer mitigation kicks in
earlier if you keep the row open longer
that's the idea over here and that's
picture kind of summarized of course
with this one you get a little bit more
Rob for locality exploitation but
hopefully you're secure well you can
prove that you're secure actually if you
set your parameters right but setting
those parameters right actually is a
difficult part as we will discuss a
little bit more so we show that you can
actually do this with low performance
overhead uh but in extreme case you can
actually get high performance overheads
also okay there's a lot more in the
paper that I will not talk about uh but
I'm happy to discuss
more any questions on this yes
please I might have missed how do you
keep
the row open for longer from like
software perspective or is that
something you did it in a control
setting can can that
system so yeah people have developed
system level Solutions like protecting
the page tables for example or adding
more isolation there's a paper sosp
that's happening right now actually that
shows that you can partition the
applications across different Subways
such that they don't interact with each
other certainly those are viable uh they
don't solve the let's say all of the
robustness issues they may solve the
security issues that happen across
applications for example but they may
not solve the safety issues for example
right yeah yes
please so R okay so there's we can go
into more detail but there's a passing
gate effect that happens essentially
it's uh yeah electrons get injected to
the through a passing gate hopefully
that gives you at least a keyword
yes
yeah
yes so you're suggesting you can detect
this and maybe that could be a solution
or okay so maybe we can talk about the
level issues later on I I wanted to keep
the abstraction level level lower higher
but there are a lot of interesting
things and people are also examining
this people are trying to model this
using tcat simulations Etc it's not easy
essentially but those two two things
that I mentioned earlier like cross talk
and electrom migration is is the electro
migration and injection are the two
major mechanisms that we know of that
leads to row Hammer row press is the
passing gate effect
essentially yes please
I
mean depends on your perspective right I
I believe it's a huge problem I don't
think we should have any bit flips in in
our systems
but this is also a very cost sensitive
part so anything that you do is
increasing your cost in the end from the
DI manufacturers perspective it's not
like they're complete completely
dragging their feet they're trying to
solve the problem but I believe they
don't know exactly how and I think all
of these issues that we have discussed
affect them directly for example aging
of the chip right I'm actually very
worried in an age the chip this could
actually become much worse that's
something we're working on uh so I don't
think there's so many dimensions to the
problem that it's not easy to solve in
my
opinion but they did drag their feet
initially I would say right now I don't
think they're dragging their
feet but they just don't know easily how
okay
okay I believe there's more to come by
the way so hopefully we'll discuss that
so I think these are the two major
objections that I would like to bring up
I think we need to understand these bit
flips a lot more and also Hardware erors
in general I generalize things a little
bit aging environmental conditions
memory access patterns system design
decision that we make all of these are
actually I think quite difficult and we
need to understand them we don't
understand some of these and solving is
also important I think flexible and
efficient Solutions are necessary and I
believe some of these Solutions need to
be patchable reconfigurable programable
and I believe you need to co across the
system and stack and
components um we have some minutes I
think feel free to think about questions
but I'm going to mention something I
think one of the things that limit
innovation in this area and that make
Solutions harder uh this also goes back
to your point I think is the interface
between DM and the memory controller
this is a very rigid interface memory
controller right now does all kinds of
Maintenance that I believe DM should be
doing that's one of the reasons I think
the DM manufacturers are not able to do
a lot of things because they have very
little time budget to do some sort of
rammer mitigation for example so this is
a paper that keeps getting rejected but
I believe it's a good idea so the idea
is basically very
simple give some autonomy to the DM chip
such that the DM chip can do some things
internal we call the self-managing DM
and the DM chip at some point can say
I'm not going to service your activat
because I have some much more important
things to do and that's the idea this is
very little change to the
interface we have an act Knack pin
essentially leveraging the ability to
reject and activate a maintenance
operation like Grammer mitigation can be
implemented completely within aam chip
and I believe this is a this a good
partitioning of uh the duties let's say
it's not just roam protection you can
actually do thees mitigation a lot of
the things that we have discussed the DI
manufacturer can figure that out and it
can do variable rate refresh Etc without
modifying the memory controller I mean
they have a memory control internally of
course now memory scrubbing Etc I'm not
going into the details of this but I
believe the sort of interface changes
are going to be going into the future
except as a top area I think those
people don't want to spend any money
onic
Gates well I think that that mentality
is changing it's a mindset issue but I I
absolutely agree that mentality was
changing because like they clearly
introduced these rowhammer counting
cells so they're adding logic gates
they're actually experimenting with
processing in memory mechanisms so I
believe that mentality will change I
believe they need to change the business
model slightly uh we we need to get out
of this memory being commodity and once
they change that business model then I
think they can justify a lot more of
those logic gates and maybe we'll have a
much better let's say system going into
the future
yes and in that is
possibility because someone exploits the
D you mean for this so absolutely but
that's true for any roh Hammer solution
meaning if if you actually have a row
Hammer Solution that's perfectly secure
you can actually cause denial of service
by actually attacking a row because
internally there will be refreshes
that's going on but this true for this
interface also and that needs to be
examined so denal of service I think you
need to be careful about but at least
you're not doing data corruption theal
service hopefully a littleit easier to
deal
with and in in the end I think it'll be
degradation of service and not complete
denial also yeah okay okay so since we
don't have a lot of time I will go
through this relatively quick I think
future is more Bleak
basically due to difficulties in
technology scaling we're going to see
more of these errors and some of them
may be happening and we don't see them
they may be going unnoticed and I
believe we need to examine these these
errors can cause safety security
vulnerabilities clearly and this is true
for all Technologies there was a
question earlier on different
Technologies I don't believe any
technology is immune uh we have not come
up with a magic memory technology yet
even though some people in the past have
claimed that some technologies over here
on this list were magic let's say so how
do we deal with it I think we need to
understand more I'm not saying anything
different we need to have more real
device data and Analysis modeling better
understanding developing reliable
metrics models we need to architect
better we need to have better
partitioning of Duties across the stack
I think one of the reasons we are
suffering today is because of that bad
partitioning of Duties across the stack
that we have between memy and processor
we clearly cannot give up performance
and efficiency but patch ability in the
field is important and I think design
and test as subash mentioned earlier is
going to be a lot more important going
into the future maybe it's going to be a
lot more online testing to actually
figure this out because offline testing
is I think in my opinion it's
insurmountable in terms of cost it's
done yeah yeah it's all online I
think okay that's why we've been
building this infrastructure and I think
we need to build more so let's get get
back to Bridges bridges have bit flips
as you can see and human beings have
been building bridges for thousands of
years and this is critical
infrastructure and we still haven't
gotten it right this is soul this is
Minneapolis Genoa and more recently
Pittsburgh where I used to live in I
used to go over that bridge many times
yeah this a Forbes Avenue Bridge if you
know Pittsburgh yeah I think we're
better than Bridges I mean here we're at
a scale that's much larger than Bridges
we are billions of devices clearly but
at least we have some better hope and
bridges are very hard to let's say uh
patch if you will right but intelligent
memory can actually patch those
failures okay let me give you some final
thoughts I like this paper this was
published in it security and privacy in
2003 actually uh took advantage of bit
flips in memory to take over a virtual
machine it's essentially a very similar
attack to what Google developed using
rammer and the way they actually induced
memory errors was actually put a lamp on
the on the system over here so you get a
lot of mem clearly it's a problemistic
attack Etc so what Ro Hammer did was
essentially replace that lamp with
software you have a simple exploitable
memory eror that can be induced by
software and that's why people are
writing articles that look like this now
and there's more
coming okay I'm going to skip some of
these over here here uh to get to the
end uh to conclude since we don't have
time so to conclude uh memory
reliability is reducing these
reliability issues open up security and
safety vulnerabilities these are very
hard to defend against uh some people
say that these are Byzantine failures do
all you can to avoid them and that's I
believe true roham is a prime example of
this as far as we know it's the first
example of how a simple Hardware failure
mechanism can cause a widespread system
security vulnerability and I find the
implications on system security and
Safety Research search tremendous and
exciting the bad news is this is getting
worse and there are other effects that
are coming up that we need to understand
the good news is we have a lot more to
do at least hopefully we're now fully
aware that Hardware is easily followable
uh there's a lot of issues in hardware
and I think we need to really be solving
all of those we're developing both
attacks and defenses at least from a
security perspective and we're hopefully
developing more principled models
methodologies and solutions I think we
need to do a lot more on this last one
over here because I think understanding
is lacking in this area that leads to
holes that are open so I'll acknowledge
my group over here you can take a look
at some of these faces and everything
I've discussed is online you can take
some of the source code run to your
laptop see if it caus bit
flips and it's on our GitHub I'm happy
to take more questions thank
you
questions yes you mention that
so yeah that's a good question so we
we've tested hbm2 chips which is not the
latest and greatest hbm3 clearly but
that's what we had access to I think
there are effects in hbm uh that is one
of the issues like temperature is one of
the issues and we see a clear problem
with ro press especially in HDM because
of the 3D stacking and temperature and
also we're investigating some 3D
stacking related issues that may not
exactly be like Ro Hammer but there are
some other blips that you can get in hbm
I believe we have a paper uh that's on
archive if you're interested in taking a
look at hbm2
results yes I is question memory all
inter
very it seems like every
is
that I mean um I I don't think it's a
fundamental issue with the
interconnectedness right it's uh I would
say it's more of a hierarchical uh
structure right uh
um but density certainly yes I would say
yeah because of the density and
closeness of these structures to each
other it's you will have some noise uh
between those structures and that's what
we're seeing with r hammer and certainly
R press and that's what why we're not
seeing it in older technologies that are
not as
dense does that answer your question I
don't think it's a fundamentally an
issue of things being interconnected
right it's just how closely they are how
close they are to each other I I think
the bigger issue is that you know as I
said that in memory only chips
especially nobody wants to spend logic
gates to do anything you know and you
know if you have you know just memory
and nothing else to get around anything
you know like what are you going to do
you know which is kind of you know like
whatever HX did you know they had to put
in some gates to Samsung also
actually intelligence yeah in the memory
chips otherwise you know and the farther
you go from memory chips and you try to
solve the problem somewhere else yeah
your visibility and diagn into the whole
thing is just not going to be there and
then you just you know just guess and do
guess work you know kind of a similar
thing is happening in logic chips now
right you know like there was a there's
a paper at sosp from Alibaba you know
following up on the Google paper the
logic chips like a significant
percentage of logic chips are defective
in the cloud you know people expect 100
defective chips per million the number
is at least in order of magnitude more
if not much more than that it's going to
get worse it's not going to get
better something fails people are just
you know like throwing darks in their
dark and they're hoping that something
good will happen and they cannot
diagnose what the source of the problem
is you mentioned the tax on on AI let's
say getting worse
or have you seen the real examples or is
this more something we've seen in the LA
[Music]
b r
or well I don't know if there are real
examples out in the field but people
have shown that using these bit flips
you can actually destroy the accuracy of
real inference engines there are a lot
of works on this topic uh I believe it's
AAR critical safety issue
yes I mean also like related to ro
Hammer we don't know if there's an
attack that's out there that affects
everyone
but uh if you don't expose these things
probably those attacks may be happening
also right that's I think that's always
the thing in the security
research yes I think like especially in
the market which is commodity market
like everything Isen right how much can
you put this particular have you ever
thought about or has the industry
thought about Solutions where they have
some sort of benchmarking or some sort
of testing environment which would like
at least
you know standardize this across like
right now I don't see this as part of my
D spe when
iank I mean yeah this is something that
di manufacturers don't want to expose
basically exactly they don't want you to
know the reliable to characteristics so
this is something that we've been
arguing also more transparency in the
reliability characteristics a better
interface better paring of Duties all of
these actually go toward that direction
actually in one paper we have an archive
we argue something like that the
manufacturers expose some
characteristics such that the memory
controls can be built on top of them to
achieve system level reliability and
robustness guarantees so I agree with
you but it's not easy to move in that
direction but there is another issue
right so to be able to even figure out
what those characteristics are that
means they have to characterize them and
it's highly unlikely that they
characterize it one time and it will
hold for the whole batch right so you
know you pretty much have to do it chip
by chip which means you know now it's
more testing cost and this and exactly
yeah I mean for there's certainly to
answer some other part of your question
there are certainly testing programs
that you can download and use right m
test 86 for example in fact those were
the press bxs that picked up on our
original paper and added a ro hammer
test and then everybody was going to
them and saying oh we had these bit
slips in the throw hammer test so
basically certainly you can do testing
uh after you assemble your system uh and
people try to do testing but testing is
a very tough thing as The Bu also
mentioned thank you
who wants to go
first that you saw from your
different different termination some
sometimes said that you
[Music]
access so you think that mainly um with
aisco or the dimensionality of the so
just just with the density of
the I think all of the it's all of the
above probably yes I mean we can go into
the Silicon level mechanism if you want
but it's all of the above in the end it
imol all of
them
yes
one of the
that security your first principle so
how do you think we can keep like
students and researchers and people in
in the
workforce
Dev system to think about
thata this the care off space and then
instead of just doing the best
performance
the
like considering space and maybe KN I
know that I'm not SEC
but well yeah I mean that's why I
propose this understanding I don't think
we're even at the point of where under
we have understood that curve for
example but
uh I mean it's a tough thing right it's
not just performance I think uh so in
the end if you want to to get lower cost
if you want to get larger memories and
that's what we want that's what
everybody wants you will have to scale
the memory technology to some smaller
dimensions and you will run into these
reliability problems I think it's more
of a mindset issue that these
reliability problems are also important
and people need to be educated on that
and there are SOL there's a solution
space there's a variety of solutions
that you can
employ
yeah so that's an excellent question uh
if you want to design something that
that is like uh highly reliable Etc cost
is always going to be higher you could
do it like people are trying to do that
for space application for example right
things are that are going to go out
space hardening many modu redundancy Etc
uh we we know the design principles over
here and we sent these things into the
space also uh but cost is very high I I
but I think there's another issue which
is
you know even what we have done in the I
actually jokingly say the 19th century
approaches but I mean the 20th century
approaches you know it had been a very
manufacturing driven uh industry and you
know and that's why I think we don't
even know what we don't know I mean you
know like to be able to solve these
problems you have to know and I think
that's a huge issue yeah that's that's
why my first point was understanding I
think I agree with that we we need to
know more about what the manufactur I
think question respect the security
there anything that operating
system yeah I mean there there are
papers on that topic one of the ideas is
physical isolation meaning waste some of
your memory such that the rols that you
are
accessing there's no data that are next
to those rows but this Wass a lot of
memory clearly uh and people have tried
to overcome the memory overheads you can
isolate different applications to
different Subways where you don't have
roll ham cover so there are some things
that you can do then you need to know
the layouts of the data that's right A
lot of these can be reverse engineered
yes that's what they sure yeah that's
the downside you need to know the layout
of DM you may not be perfectly correct
but yes people have proposed a lot of
those
Solutions this the last
question
so um you have two adjacent RS and place
those two capacitors in a different
layer that we have more distance between
the neighboring capacitors I know it's
very deep but it's this type of solution
has been discussing in last device to
avoid
Cross or capacit in very low layers M so
what would but you waste
spaceace
have something else come next to it and
then that become
the but you will waste space in one of
the layers right in each individual
layer yes yeah so I think that's
absolutely I think the solutions can
waste space so for example the
manufacturers can insert additional
distance Etc it's not easy in this in
today's technology but you can you can
reduce the distance increase the
distance Etc and you can reduce this
problem no question about that but all
of those Solutions come at cost
chice basically yeah okay thank you very
much H sure thanks thank you for the
questions